today i want to talk about lists teresa
monica sherman
lisa so as many of you could probably
guess this topic has come up because
there was a list that went around
recently that should not have gone
around i'm gonna give this one voldemort
treatment so i don't have to link it
because i really don't want to divert
any more traffic to it if you don't know
what i'm talking about the short version
is that there's a major publication that
put out a major list recently ranking
albums and
yeah it's really bad
for a lot of reasons
so bad that i'm afraid to invoke it by
name because if i do maybe i'll be
haunted by the people who made the list
i think it's bad for more reasons than
just what is and isn't on the list and
yeah i think i have some thoughts i'd
like to share about lists in general if
you guys would humored me so let's start
at the very beginning basic list what is
it one two three stuff like that you're
listing items please stick with me i
promise i'm going somewhere i think the
human brain loves lists we love having
some structure that we can follow and
with a list you know there's something
coming up next and you know that there's
probably an end if it's a numbered list
growing up my dad had a lot of things
that he would say repeatedly and
it's the sort of thing we could make a
list of but one of the things he'd say
is make a list and he's definitely right
because yeah lists are great lists have
all kinds of purposes you can make a
list of things you need to pick up at
the grocery store you can make a list of
things you need to do in minecraft and
of course in the context that i want to
talk about people make lists of their
favorite albums favorite movies things
like that so yeah i'm a human being i'm
assuming you are as well and we love
lists as a result however the internet
era has taken advantage of that love in
creating some frankenstein's monster
known as the listicle
listicle of course is a portmanteau of
list and article
so this refers to articles that are
simply lists why are these such a thing
well people love the lists so they
generate a lot of traffic any website
that's looking for views that's looking
to generate attention naturally if they
put out some kind of list that is of
interest to their target audience then
people are going to click on it because
it's fun to read a list you know it's
going to end eventually
and you can look at it and agree or
disagree with it and just have a good
time it's an easy read so yes i am pro
list i think they are cool but i'm here
today as a non-expert you know just some
guy who surfs the web to talk a little
bit about list literacy or maybe
listeracy if you're so inclined so to
start this discussion i want to talk
about the things that i think make a bad
list
first is very basic and just deals with
the internet listicle phenomenon in
general but anytime i see a list that
has multiple web pages
red flag for me and that's you know for
the simple reason that they're obviously
doing it for traffic because you're
requiring the user to view multiple
pages on your website you're getting
more ad revenue on each page i don't
trust it i don't trust a list like that
i don't trust something like that
obviously there's a lot of lists that
are going to have multiple pages
especially if there are hundreds of
items on the list so yeah i i think it's
a little nefarious but it doesn't ruin a
list for me now getting into the real
meat of stuff that i think makes a bad
list i think one thing to watch out for
is objective language my experience in
the american public education system
when i was a kid you know they taught us
the difference between a fact and an
opinion surprisingly some people still
struggle with this but there's a little
more nuance to it in the fact that there
are two types of opinions in my opinion
subjective and objective opinions you
might be asking yourself what is an
objective opinion how is that real that
sounds like an oxymoron you're right it
is but it is also a real thing that
people put out there let me just give
you an example first if i were to say i
love dogs that's clearly a subjective
opinion that's what i feel about dogs if
i were to come out here and say dogs are
the best animal that's still an opinion
but it's presented as an objective
opinion it's presented in a way that i'm
trying to state some objective truth and
the other thing there is if i just tell
you i love dogs you can't argue with
that but if i try to tell you dogs are
the best immediately you could argue
with i think cats are the best and of
course that's how we end up in these
debates that go nowhere so therein lies
my problem with objective language on a
list if you're going to make a list of
say your favorite albums i think it's
important to denote that they are your
favorite if you're going to use language
like the best or the top albums yeah
it's what i think is the best but
somebody's going to see that and think
that i'm stating objectively that that's
the best which
isn't really possible i personally want
to avoid language like the best because
who am i i can tell you what my favorite
is i can tell you what you know my top
albums are personally but what do i know
what the best is because the best is
going to be different for any given
person especially when you're talking
about art along those same lines another
thing i like to watch out for is
definitives
saying things like of all time the best
of all time yeah it's fun to make lists
like that or at least take a crack at it
but time is changing time is a flat
circle it's a straight line
i don't what am i talking about oh time
moves in one direction okay what that
means is as soon as you make a list
claiming it's the greatest of all time
and then something else comes out your
list is immediately obsolete so for that
reason i'd say it's good to be careful
also saying of all time you know that
can be daunting and i think that is
another problem that i see with lists is
a lack of parameters we're all humans
you know we all make mistakes if i were
to make a list of the greatest albums of
all time there's plenty of albums that i
haven't heard so i'm missing out on a
lot of stuff that people are going to
argue why did you include this album
that you've never heard of
well because i've never heard of it but
that's why parameters are good maybe
limited to certain genres or certain
years or something like that where you
feel comfortable enough to say you've
heard enough that you can make a list
and even then you haven't because
there's things that some guy in the
comments is going to tell you you missed
last thing i want to talk about is
causing issues for lists as multiple
inputs now i'm assuming for this section
that for example pitchfork.com is
watching my video but this is really
applicable to publications or groups of
people making a list together you have a
list with a lot of people contributing
to it how do you balance those things a
lot of times it doesn't even make sense
and who do you hold accountable for the
awful inclusions that's a reference to
the list that shall not be named who do
you hold accountable for the bad
inclusions we don't know who put that
one on there we just know that it came
from the ultimate source so there's
confusion there there's obviously
inconsistency based on people's opinions
based on people's tastes i think you can
do it right with multiple inputs and
i'll talk about that too later but in
general if you're going to make some
lists it's probably going to be opinions
so why would you want to share that with
somebody else so now that i have the
negatives out there i want to talk about
some of the things that i think make a
good list
the first a big one is transparency
whether it's an individual making it or
a publication it's good to let people
that are viewing the list know how it is
that you made the list that you did any
considerations that went into the
ordering or the parameters and in the
case of a list with multiple inputs and
a lot of different people contributing
it's very important to explain how those
contributions are balanced a big one for
someone like me is recognizing
limitations like i said before there's
plenty of things that i haven't heard of
plenty movies i haven't watched so if i
were to make some kind of list it's
important for me to acknowledge yeah
i've never really listened to this
artist's catalog like that or i need to
go back and listen to certain things
before i can include it that again leads
into the whole idea of definitives being
dangerous because we all have
limitations but if we're unwilling to
recognize them the list isn't going to
turn out very good and lastly another
big thing is a willingness to change the
list sometimes it's not practical if
you're doing a year-end list but maybe
you're somebody who wants to revisit
that year-end list a year later and see
how things change if you're going to
make one of those dangerous greatest of
all time lists it would be worthwhile to
continue to update it as new things come
out that belong on the list i think that
lends some credibility and while it's
still a dangerous list you can at least
make it better so while i could have
gone for the easy content pulled up the
list that shall not be named and sat
here and complained about all the things
i disagreed about i thought maybe a
better practice right now to close this
out would be to give you some lists that
i do like some lists that i do return to
the first as a movie guy is the imdb top
250. i like that list because it is
transparent almost to a level that's
dangerous because they tell you exactly
how they include the votes of different
people the fact that they weigh votes
more based on how many movies certain
accounts have rated and it is always
subject to change because new movies
come out everybody bombs those reviews
with high ratings and then next thing
you know avengers is on there for a
month it may not be like the most
accurate reflection of critically
acclaimed stuff but it is democratic and
i like the idea of just everyday joes
telling you what their favorite movies
are and then we are able to come to some
kind of consensus about what is the most
important i think the music equivalent
of that would be write your music they
have top albums of all time and i like
that one too again i don't necessarily
agree with all the albums that are the
highest but that's kind of the point
everybody who uses that site rates the
albums how they rate them and then
however the site does it it aggregates
the favorites into a list i'm not sure
how transparent they are with if they
weigh things differently but again i do
like a democratic list and i do like it
when it's based on a huge sample size of
potentially thousands hundreds of
thousands of people another list that i
like which is also aggregated but based
on critics is of course metacritic's
year-end lists of best albums and movies
metacritic does a great job explaining
the system they take in all the lists
from different publications and they
tell you how many points are going to be
assigned to different albums or movies
based on how they rank for each critic
and i think the point system works out
really well and then eventually you have
this frankenstein metacritic telling you
what the highest rated albums or movies
were of a given year and it's cool to
see because sometimes an album might be
highly rated throughout the year but
then by the end of the year critics have
forgotten about it and are valuing other
things so it's cool to just see that
contrast too metacritic's great love
them the last one i want to give a shout
out to is david ehrlich who is a film
critic for indiewire he makes these
really great video lists of i think it's
25 movies every year obviously it's good
because it's just one guy so we know
it's his opinion but also he puts a lot
of effort into the editing he uses clips
from the movies and soundtracks it with
songs from the movies and i just think
there's a lot of care and love put into
those lists of course obviously no one's
gonna agree with his lists entirely
because they're his lists but it's fun
for me to go to those lists and find a
movie i've never heard of tucked in
between two that i love and say okay
maybe i should check that out that's
where i think lists are incredibly
useful even if they're a bad list just
giving you something to look through
something to pull from and to educate
yourself i'm not an expert in any kind
of music but if i were to look at one of
those lists i'm sure to find a lot of
albums that i've not heard of that
wouldn't make the list if i made it
today but i can use that and say okay
let me check these out somebody's
telling me it's important so here we are
it's the middle of the year and i've got
a list that i'm going to be working on i
made one last year obviously it's my
mid-year list of albums and songs that
i've been liking i'm obviously going to
tell you that they're my favorites not
the best my parameters of course is that
it came out this year and given we're
only halfway through the year i don't
feel comfortable ranking them yet which
is why i did it last year and i'll do it
again i'm going to rank them
alphabetically for the mid-year and if
you can't tell what i'm doing is
exercising transparency and showing you
how my list works thank you all for
watching i hope this was interesting
it's a little different but you know i'm
trying to do different things and make
these long videos hopefully you enjoyed
it and of course always always watch out
for clickbait watch out for those red
flag lists i do not trust like that i
don't trust like that